la gira 'vivir tiene luz cuando pakistán
atravesaba uno de los días más críticos
por las inundaciones que dejaron un
tercio del país bajo el agua a poco
tiempo del nacimiento tuvo que abandonar
su hogar y resguardarse con su hija en
la carretera ahora que cesaron las
lluvias y se encuentra en un refugio
provisional teme por la seguridad de su
hija
lo único que queremos es que arreglen
nuestra casa al menos lo suficiente para
poder ir a casa porque aquí los niños
duermen afuera sin ventilador hay
mosquitos y duele ver a los niños
tirados aquí a dicha joven yo no duro
natalie portman
pero este no es un caso aislado unicef
estima que 16 millones de niños están
afectados por las inundaciones y que 34
millones necesitan asistencia
humanitaria además las lluvias se han
cobrado la vida de unos 400 niños un
tercio de los fallecidos en pakistán y a
pesar de que el agua ha dado tregua las
enfermedades acechan a los menores del
país
enfermedades vinculadas con el agua
diarrea cólera todas las enfermedades
que puedas imaginar llegarán muy pronto
la situación también es crítica para las
mujeres embarazadas el país carece de
médicos suministros y lugares adecuados
para permitir partos seguros
estoy embarazada de 8 meses tengo
dolores de parto tengo problemas aquí en
el campamento
necesitamos un médico o al menos una
enfermera que nos pueda ayudar hay más
mujeres embarazadas en el campamento en
estas condiciones no sé a dónde aorta de
cesárea
según cifras de la onu 650 mil mujeres
embarazadas se encuentran en las áreas
afectadas por las inundaciones
pakistán recibió casi un 190 por ciento
más de lluvia que su promedio de 30 años
en el trimestre de juego